John echo is respected as one of the
best hunters around here he's hunted
most of his life when he been didn't
meet us at the house that we feel very
very happy and we don't have anything
that he will not be happy that one
tradition here diversity you cannot be
eating empty food
he caught a rodent in the forest for his
family's meal today Cameroon has banned
the hunting of endangered species now
why hunter did you do to prison by they
he means the Rangers here in coral
National Park in the west of the country
Park Rangers considered a good job
Brenda Moo grew up in a city and there
are no hunters in her family but she's
learnt to spot the traces hunters leave
behind
I don't smite with hanta because I know
that one destroying our forests I don't
joke with contest when I meet a hunter
yeah I will show him that I am a human
with a different don't realize forbidden
to enter Cove National Park on hunt
it's a real problem people living in
what is now the National Park have
always eaten animals they find in the
rainforest including species that are
now endangered the conservation
authorities are getting tougher as they
seek to protect them from extinction
representatives of an NGO are visiting
the park with the Rangers
they're setting up camera traps to help
them make an inventory of the shrinking
populations of the endangered species
such as chimpanzees and drills
[Music]
forest animals are a primary source of
protein for people here some animals are
also sold to outsiders
it's one of very few ways to make any
money
[Music]
the villagers area is located within the
national park the parks director has
come to visit when he was here two years
ago the Welcome wasn't so warm
but now the park administration and the
villagers work together if they abide by
the rules they receive significant
material benefits such as solar
electricity this time they keep the
local people become the center of
conservation efforts so for the first
time we were consulted at every stages
where we became convinced of the fact
that we could have different ways of
earning a living inside the National
Park what alternatives are there to
hunting the villagers and the park
administration have together agreed on
different zones and set up signs to mark
their boundaries the protected
rainforest the communal forest where
local people can gather wood and the
area where they can farm John Eck poor
the former hunter has been farming for
years he's approaching 60 and hunting
was becoming very tiring he grows cocoa
bananas and mangos
but conservationists want to persuade
other hunters to follow his example john
Ekpo says he and his family are better
off now as farmers and 100 town france
even as it I'm mark I thought I live now
just please I'm going on ground because
it's very easy money I don't know about
your administrator hacia I can't let her
I'm putting through colitis maybe
everything is very easy if I only how
does he break it
pilatus one answer not not a hard-ass
used to have a lot of foliar hunters
spend long
days and long nights in the forest it's
a dangerous occupation so why don't they
all turn to farming if I have a problem
and I need money immediately it's it you
go for the way to get the money cocoa
trees okay it takes some times this
cocoa trees here you have to plant them
you can plant some food crops when you
plant them so you have some first income
and there is a bear fruits after four
years so there's some difficult time to
pass at the village assembly the village
chief has proclaimed a ban on hunting
the heads of all the families agree to
the ban and to the penalties for
infringement ten men surrender their
guns to the Park Rangers
in exchange the village gets ten
motorbikes now these men have to learn
how to drive them there used to be
hunters now they hope to earn money as
couriers or by providing taxi services
that's an option now that a path has
been opened connecting air at with the
outside world before that you had to
hike for six hours to reach the nearest
village in the rainy season when the
river was high even that wasn't possible
the new bridge is said to be completed
by April Azam is very important to have
access to the market but also access to
other services er okay
would scampi can come into the village
and the people can also easier go to
school see the doctor and other Singh
Sir John Eck PO says he hopes they don't
widen the path he doesn't want to see
illegal logging destroy the forest and
his world is infested forest is appear i
am ieaving the I said I also can't
disappear
[Music]
you